Welcome, welcome, welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ] Thank you very much.
Enjoy yourself. Welcome to the show, guys.
This is a big day in business news.
I saw that JetBlue is offering to buy Spirit Airlines
for $3.6 billion.
Yeah. Right now Spirit is like,
"Guys, we better open a bank account.
I think -- I think it's time -- I think it's time, yeah."
[ Laughter ] Don't worry.
It'll still be the same Spirit Airlines,
except now every seat will have a TV that doesn't work
and a bag of Blue Chips.
Yeah.
And listen to this.
Uber just announced that it will introduce
plane bookings in the U.K.
Planes. Yeah.
If you thought talkative drivers were annoying...
"So, then I tried my hand at woodworking,
but that didn't pan out, so..."
[ Laughter ]
Has anyone here been on former President Trump's
social-media app, Truth Social?
Well, that's the problem. Anyway, it's --
[ Laughter ]
Apparently Trump is upset, he's furious,
'cause his Truth Social app is a flop.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Yep.
Trump hasn't been this mad about an app since someone sent him
Buffalo cauliflower tenders by mistake.
[As Trump] "What is this?
I want the fingers of the chicken please.
In the shape of a dinosaur. Thank you."
Yep. Truth Social isn't very popular.
At this point, even Rudy Giuliani's
OnlyFans account has more traffic.
[ Laughter ] That's right.
Trump is furious 'cause other than Trump Airlines,
Trump Steak, Trump Vodka,
Trump Mortgage, "Trump" Magazine,
and Trump University,
it is the first business fail of his career.
So, yeah.
Well, I read that as bird flu
continues to spread across the country,
zoos are moving their birds inside
to protect them from the virus.
It's weird. Right now all of the birds
are stuck inside making sourdough
and watching "Tiger King."
[ Laughter ] Isn't that weird?
-Wow.
-You guys see this?
Just in time for baseball season,
Frito-Lay is selling a new version of Cracker Jacks
called Cracker Jill.
Take a look at this. Yeah.
So, yeah, we can all stop worrying about gender equality.
We did it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Cracker Jill.
[ Applause ]
Well, this seems impossible. A scientist in the U.K. claims
that mushrooms communicate with each other
using up to 50 different "words."
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure the study was conducted
by a scientist on mushrooms.
That probably makes some better sense.
Oh, I'm kidding. He sounds like a fungi. Uh...
"What's that? Five picture deal with Pixar?
Sure. Let's go for six."
Hey, guys. It is time to take a look at the stories
making headlines today and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons." Here we go.
-♪ Pros and Cons and Pros and Cons and Pros ♪
-Tonight we'll be taking a look at the pros and cons
of springtime in New York.
I love New York,
but it's especially beautiful in the spring.
Let's take a look at the pros and cons
of springtime in New York.
Here we go. Pro...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That's where it was."
It's a rare Duane Reade bird.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
He can pull it off. Yeah. -Come on.
"Yeah. Like this? I got it at Spiffany's."
-Yeah.
It's like, "Uh, it's raining. Just -- Yeah, how much?
Whatever, whatever." Sproing!
Oh, there you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And lastly...
That's the "Pros and Cons," everybody.
Thank you very much. Springtime in New York.